i want to thank you all for sending me
in so many woke commercials to try to
guess what product
they are selling i don't have a great
record on them
so far i think i'm two for 12 at the
moment
but you know okay that's not nothing i'm
gonna try to redeem myself i think i'm
getting better at this
i've picked up my prognostication
abilities as it's gone on
before we get started i want to mention
this video is sponsored by our friends
at ring
with ring you can give the gift of smart
home security
more from them later but first i'm ready
to increase
my success rate let's roll the woke ed
i miss you happy holidays can we talk
uh okay he's away so i'd say it could be
like
he's obviously not in the army or
anything
okay
[Music]
is the one you make
it's a gay thing there's love there's
family right this could be food i'm
gonna say
yeah okay well okay taste of welcome
that was so fast i i want to take
victory on that one
because the only thing other than
all of the kind of sexual signaling in
there the only thing was the food
and so i would have thought it was like
those little like
tostito type things there or whatever
food but i'm gonna take a victory on
that
i didn't get the cracker but i did know
it was food let's roll the next one
to my beautiful black baby you're being
born into a country with history
a history of violence against your skin
for you still have to fight for the care
you
need but this moment is a reckoning to
change the story of skin
while you're being born america is being
rebuilt we're like a healthcare thing
we're on a 400 year long journey
and scars don't fade but neither does
hope
vaseline vaseline ah
you know i don't i kind of i'm gonna
i'll give myself half credit on that
because there are you know women do they
put like vaseline on their stomachs so
they don't get marks and things like
that
so it's i guess it's healthcare i would
have expected it to be more like a kind
of
hospital network or you know some kind
of medical supply vaseline though it is
again it is healthcare
so i'm going to take a 50 on that i feel
like we're getting a little bit better
i didn't think i knew that wasn't going
to be woke on the kind of planned
parenthood ends of things that wasn't
going to work very well or on the
you know that much more political realm
i had a feeling okay this is good both
a little more focused than they were in
the past and yet
if you weren't paying attention to every
single second you would have no idea
what they were actually
selling because what they're really
selling is politics it's doorbell season
the busiest time of year at your front
door
that's definitely true at my house right
now there's
more craziness going on you got packages
you got deliveries you got
your mother-in-law stepping over so
you're going to want to know who's at
your door okay you're going to want to
keep an eye on that
know whether whether or not you want to
open the door no matter where you are
you can do that whether you're in the
house whether you're at the office
whether you're on vacation
if somebody stops by or something's
going on ring will
let you know and you can see and speak
to whoever is there from anywhere this
holiday season
it's not just the best time to have ring
but the best time to give it
two ring makes a perfect christmas gift
this christmas season
give someone the gift of peace of mind i
think about this when i travel away from
home
sweet little elise is a good shot but i
want to make sure that we can see who's
at the front door i'm so happy
especially now that i've got a place in
beautiful tennessee i'm so happy that i
can see
who is outside of my door without having
to open that door for a limited time go
to ring.com
slash knowles kennedy wles for special
holiday offers that is ring.com
knowles k-n-w-l-e-s i'm on a roll i'm
feeling good i'm feeling safe and secure
i want what am i four
four out of 14 now let's roll the tape i
want to have a perfect score today
[Music]
it's going to be a skin or a hair thing
[Music]
it looks like skin doesn't it yeah
being white in america is not needing to
state that your life matters
because if you do you be told it doesn't
[Music]
when your life matters you
have power okay
now is the time to use that power so
it's it's got to be skin
right because it's just all kind of
wrote the lm stuff
the anti-racist oh it's going to be is
it going to be like you know
change the color of band-aids or
something or change the color of skin
makeup
read listen donate plan march vote
speak out step in okay come on get
what's the product
oh you use your powers of choice choose
action
over observation yeah uh-huh this i've i
mean you have no idea
the only thing you've seen is a proctor
gamble man
i'm just gonna start guessing procter
and gamble i think if i
just guessed from the beginning of the
commercial proctor and gamble
just from the outset i would have like a
60 at this point
okay well i guess i guess that one
doesn't doesn't quite count but i don't
know two out of three ain't bad two out
of three
ain't bad thank you for training me to
be able to read
past the deluge of wokeness and see
what's really going on
underneath at least to some degree send
in more of your woke videos
i look forward to using all of my expert
powers of analysis
to guess what they are selling see you
next time
you